The Iron Dome is hailed as the world’s
most effective air defense system,
boasting an interception success
rate of 90%, according to Israel.
But recent events are challenging that perception.
Hamas’ surprise attack is exposing
the system’s vulnerabilities.
The Iron Dome can detect rockets
fired from 43 miles or 70 km away.
It relies on a radar unit that detects when
a missile is launched and relays information
about its speed and trajectory to the control unit
- the brains of the system, which rapidly assesses
what kind of projectile is in the air and where it
could potentially land using advanced algorithms.
Harmless trajectories are ignored. However, if
the control unit believes it’s heading for a
populated area or an area of strategic importance,
the launcher fires missiles to intercept the enemy
rocket by exploding near it while not making
direct contact with it. Each Iron Dome system,
often referred to as a “battery”, consists
of 3 or 4 launchers each equipped with
20 missiles. The system is mobile so
it can move to wherever it’s needed.
Ten batteries are placed strategically throughout
the country, each defending an
area of up to 60 square miles.
They don 't protect every inch of Israel’s
total area of 9,000 square miles. Instead,
they’re strategically placed to
protect populated areas and key assets.
If they didn’t exist, Israeli tanks would have
to roll into Gaza immediately to stop
the rocket fire like they did in 2009.
To date, the U.S. has invested $2.6
billion in the Iron Dome defense system.
The Iron Dome has been the backbone of
Israel’s multi-layered defense since 2011,
with thousands of successful interceptions.
However, that backbone appeared
to crack on October 7th, 2023.
Right now a massive barrage of rockets
coming off of the Gaza strip. This is
an effort by Hamas and Islamic jihad
to overhwelm Israel’s defense system.
Whatever happened in the early hours of morning,
the iron dome was not able to stop this barrage.
The iron dome was not able to stop this barrage
Hamas unleashed an astonishing
number of rockets from Gaza:
they claim 5,000 in a span of 20 minutes.
The Israeli Defense Forces
put the number at 2,200.
Even taking the lower figure, the intensity of
this attack is remarkable when compared to the
50-day conflict in 2014, during which a total ofb
4,000 rockets were fired from Gaza into Israel.
The Israeli Defense Forces have not
disclosed the number of rockets intercepted
However, evidence shows rockets
raining down on indiscriminate targets,
leaving buildings destroyed
and hundreds of people dead.
Iran’s state-affiliated Nour
News mockingly described the
Iron Dome as “nothing but a dome
of straw above a sand castle.”
The Iron Dome’s Tamir interceptors are neither
infinite nor cheap, costing around $50,000 each.
In contrast, Hamas’ rudimentary Qassam
rockets that are fuelled by a mixture of
sugar and everyday fertilizer
cost $300 - $800 per launch.
The sheer number of rockets Hamas was able
to secretly amass has led to questions.
How did Israeli intelligence fail
to detect the growing stockpile?
It has one of the most advanced intelligence
agencies in the world and
works closely with the CIA.
It was an intelligence failure.
Was Israel too preoccupied with other
threats like the more potent Hezbollah?
These are questions that Israeli
officials have so far failed to answer.
The U.S. swiftly responded to the surprise
attacks by bolstering Israel’s
depleted Iron Dome interceptors.
Since 2014, major American military
contractor Raytheon has partnered with
Israel’s Rafael Advanced Defense Systems to craft
components for the Tamir interceptor missiles.
While the intention has been to support
Israel, this collaboration has also enhanced
U.S. defense capabilities. Two batteries
have been supplied to the U.S. Army.
But faith in the Iron Dome isn’t universal.
MIT professor Ted Postol who is an expert on
missile technology believes the Iron
Dome is not as reliable as it appears.
He estimates its success rate during the November
2012 conflict between Israel and Hamas
might have been 5 percent or less.
His evidence? Photographic documentation
of missile exhaust flight paths.
For the Iron Dome missile to neutralize
an enemy rocket effectively, it should
confront it head-on. However, Professor Postol’s
research indicates the missiles often attacked
from the side which is a serious problem,
or from behind, which is also ineffective.
In MIT Technology Review, he elaborates:
“If the interceptor hits the back end
of the rocket…the warhead will almost
certainly go on to the ground and explode.”
Professor Postol suggested that
the "Iron Dome radar tracking and
guidance system is not working" and
this sparked significant controversy.
Israel's Ministry of Defence
dismissed his claims as "baseless",
maintaining their confidence in the Iron Dome.
I reached out to Professor Postol
for his current take on the Iron
Dome's effectiveness but have not heard back.
An intriguing sentiment from a 2021
Foreign Policy article suggests:
“...Israel’s air defenses may one day not
be enough to hinder volumes of rockets.
Israel won’t admit this, but there is
a strategic peak for this technology.”
While the Iron Dome has kept Israel’s
citizens safe for over a decade,
it’s clearly not infallible.
The recent surprise attacks reveal
the cracks in the Iron Dome,
underscoring that even the world’s most
advanced defense system…has its limits.
As we discuss advanced defense
technologies like the Iron Dome,
one can't help but wonder about the historical
events that necessitate such innovations.
I’ve recently been binging Curiosity Stream, which
has award-winning documentaries about history.
I’m currently watching The History of
Mossad, the Israeli foreign intelligence
agency that was founded to guarantee
the ongoing existence of Israel.
You cannot have a true reading of the history
of Israel, the history of the whole world,
without understanding the secret
history of its intelligence service.
Curiosity Stream has thought-provoking and
original documentaries you won’t find anywhere
else, spanning science, nature, technology,
military history, music, food, and more.
Like the beautiful original documentary
Light on Earth with David Attenborough.
If you love to learn, check out
curiositystream.com/Newsthink
or scan the QR code on your
screen for watch the world’s top documentaries and
nonfiction series. The link is in the description.
And use my promo NEWSTHINK to save 25% off.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.